vah vah vah her Flo tries to mediate but
even seemingly minor problems can be
hard to solve a preschool student is in
shock after a friend pushed the pen into
her ear
hey Hades real problems are much bigger
and many think the nation has no real
future in spite of the massive help that
is poured in since the 2010 earthquake
but some believe Haiti can heal itself I
want to find out how realistic that
dream is the plant oneness that's it
Hannah and water got problems Oh Fergus
done dr. hoodless mobile clinic is a
common sight in to school she came to
haiti 15 years ago from Cologne Germany
and since then has been treating
children in the poorest parts of the
capital boho cos the hotel doctor who
fleur points out the swollen lymph nodes
on this girl's neck it may be an
indication of leukemia she's not
equipped to deal with illnesses of this
magnitude she didn't really see much of
the billions in post-earthquake
donations yeah oh my gosh cassandra
kennedy that money never made it to the
poor she tells me it went to the big
organizations they use most of it to pay
their employees to finance the big jeeps
they drive the nice houses they live in
noise
and I see no sign of it in slums like
city LA where the school is located as
many as 400,000 people live here in
extreme poverty but even in the slums
there's a class system and if you end up
in the neighborhood of tiet you've hit
rock bottom dr. her flea is a frequent
visitor here maybe that's why some
caller the crazy German doctor who keys
have finally caught but why does she
keep on doing all this let's mosey
ominous I wish I knew I asked if she
remembers why she first came here for to
finish class and cannot have I them I
wanted to work with children on the
street and did so for two years she says
but then I started working in small
schools I think the next generation is
the only chance that remains for Haiti
that's the main reason I'm still here
the antigua casa de caja it easier on
des up this is M after how contra which
besides nokia where dr. her flea insists
that i take a closer look at tiet using
fit I'm ended of it this is the end of
the world she says nobody else dares
come here to sonst auch eine hint open
areas like this are used both as garbage
dumps and communal toilets the stench is
indescribable
the garbage serves as fodder for the
pigs and toys for the children Leila de
veau agrees to show me her shanty she
lives here with her six children
fighbird school only the youngest is at
home Leila does not have a husband and
there's nothing to eat that's often the
way it is Leila would need less than one
euro a day to feed her family a tiny
fraction of the estimated 3.3 billion
euros donated since the earthquake but
Lebanon set alessa Metellus nobody came
to help me and my children after the
earthquake Leila tells me my biggest
problem now is that I have no means to
earn money and to live here with my six
children satsang e equal problem neva
when began mukha bummer dr. her flaw
points out human suffering everywhere
including a boy who went blind because
no funds were available to treat him but
he not its social status or the family
with a mentally ill mother and an
undernourished baby right next door
thousands of NGOs are obviously
incapable of eliminating this kind of
human misery and the corrupt political
system in Haiti is completely
dysfunctional so what options are still
available one idea tourism Haiti has an
international travel destination I want
to find out if that's a dream worth
pursuing
the first hurdle is escaping the traffic
gridlock in poho Klaus once that's
behind me I'm off to the north along
with my private tour guide Sasha duo she
she's of European descent that's why she
has fair skin she's also haitian to the
core and believes in her country
patients are very big hearts they're not
closed like in Europe where people don't
say hello to you when you walk in the
streets people say hello to you people
say thank you to you
it's very different from any place I
ever been to accompanying us is the
first english-language guidebook for
Haiti published since the earthquake I'm
astounded at how green the north of the
island is just six hours away from the
dusty foul-smelling capital hidden above
the tropical vegetation is a real
tourist gem that getting there is truly
difficult here we meet Gretel and Jaclyn
they will guide us to a UNESCO World
Heritage Site Gretel has the worst part
of the deal she has to carry tourists a
short 10-minute ride gives us a first
glimpse of a monument some compared to
Machu Picchu la cita de la feria the
largest fortress in the Americas it was
built at the beginning of the 19th
century to protect the former slaves and
the young Republic from recolonization
up to 20,000 workers spent 15 years
building it including dragging hundreds
of cannons up the mountain the result
was a practically impregnable stronghold
los que leisure vse esche antigua last
anesthetic way up georgia claw tells me
that when people come here they just say
wow because it's so fantastic because
the citadel is the eighth wonder of the
world only haiti can boast a stronghold
like this la cita del la feria last time
dan de Lafayette the problem is we're
basically the only ones to enjoy this
view a couple of un staffers have made
their way up the steep mountain there
are days when nobody comes but it's
enough for Jean to make a living
compared to the slum dwellers he's well
off he is confident that the Citadel has
much bigger potential and I can see
1,000 visitors a day easily were it not
for some serious obstacles Gong ha the
exhausting journey to get here for
example and the lack of safety barriers
it's hard for me to imagine package
tourist groups with kids and seniors up
here nevertheless Jean is hopeful
because not far away behind this
mountain the american norwegian company
royal caribbean operates the Cruz Harbor
la body
al camion he has infested a comprar Jean
tells me royal caribbean aside the
contract to bring tourists in the
Citadel year that's supposed to start in
a couple of months it may mean low okay
okay okay okay I can come ask if things
will change that yes he replies it will
change and that makes me happy whea say
oui oui this is what it looks like
behind the mountain labadee a mecca for
cruise ships on this day one of the
biggest in the world has anchored here
the Oasis of the Seas with about 5,000
passengers this man got the ball rolling
in la body Hans Buddha shoot is a
fifth-generation German in Haiti almost
30 years ago the port agent convince
royal caribbean to lease this terrain
via an give an SEO noro this was swamp
in jungle before construction began he
says so at first we didn't have a clue
that this would turn into something so
big wish to be a hundred kinda I know
the Ashanti she had reverted now about
five hundred thousand tourists visit
every year and that translates into jobs
artists and souvenir vendors can earn a
living there are also about 250 full
time employees here they're pay 15 US
dollars a day about three times the
amount they could expect outside of this
enclaves as he strolls around should is
swamped by job requests I was relying a
new game on ship couldn't Bobby a kind
of man as long as nobody dies you don't
want even more people he says what we do
now is take the best employees we learn
English and transfer them to the ships
there they can work as cleaners or room
Stewart's and so on I asked if that's
what they want yes he replies everybody
wants that but first they have to learn
English is my English Patient and that's
simply not realistic for most especially
when they're on the wrong side of la
bodies fence without a real education
without work should deny discuss the
harsh contrast between vacation paradise
in labadee and haitian daily life he's
familiar with the moral argument after
the earthquake there were forceful
requests to shut down operations in la
body as a result the people who worked
here were frightened for their
livelihoods she counsels when I'm going
to say the exact my name is had a funny
Phil should recalls they told him you
guys are out of your mind there's this
earthquake in Poho pasta and we've lost
friends and family but now you want to
create this artificial earthquake for us
and take away all our jobs Harlequins
the average place to victim so the
cruise ship passengers kept on coming
although many did not even know they
were in Haiti at the time the brochures
didn't mention it until three years ago
the official description of la body was
paradise on the island of Hispaniola
that's been changed and the name Haiti
does not seem to scare tourists off but
I know Haiti is it's not a vacation
place in in that sense for most people
but I mean look at this this is as good
as it get the idyllic scenery is limited
behind this hill it's over that's where
the country's second city cafe on offers
the stark reality of Haitian life this
bridge is the only route to the Citadel
even if there is a contract the tour
operators won't be showing this to their
clients
as I gather images i hear angry mumbling
why do journalists always show the
horrible stuff one asks so to wrap
things up I give one of the young men
Claude vittata unemployed like most here
the chance to say something heartfelt
something he's proud of in his country
one maybe one dear mom nine man let's
just not forgive me first of all I love
my contact he says but my dream is that
the situation will change that we get a
beautiful new Haiti that we wake up one
morning and everything has changed for
the better I'm the day they yours yeah
didn't say we move on any memorable
that's something I would love to see
happen and I've seen that there is
potential to change Haiti from the
inside but for now the reality is that
mostly Haiti is not a place of dreams
but of despair
you